you have work to do the patient
case can
[Music]
get good
morning it's one of those weeks for me
where I have lots of small deadlines and
a couple of big deadlines on the horizon
on top of medical school whilst also
trying to balance personal life when
life becomes overwhelming what I find
helpful is to Simply write down all the
tasks on my planner and also put it on
my calendar to set up reminders this
frees up my mental energy because I
don't have to constantly keep track of
what needs to be done so it allows me to
focus better on the task at hand and
[Music]
Stressless
currently I'm on Psychiatry block again
and I need to be at the hospital at 9:
so let's
[Music]
[Applause]
go now I'm writing down the notes of a
patient I saw today because I'll need to
present the patient's case to the
consultant in a bit on a team's meeting
but for the presenting part I'll be
going home because it's online and I'd
rather do it in my own
[Music]
room we would want to review his alcohol
detox he could also take essential amino
acids an omega-3 tablet to help the
healing process from his brain injury
[Music]
I just had a life study session with
some of you these sessions always
motivate me and help me get so much work
done because I feel like we're in this
together and we're keeping each other
accountable I also feel like I've
accomplished something with my day so
that feels
good
our house is hosting a dinner for our
friendship group tonight it's going to
be for 13 people Everyone is bringing a
dish I'll be baking brownies and Yen
will be cooking a special dish so we're
on our way to the shop to get some
ingredients I also need to check the
recipe I don't know exactly what to buy
I'm asking my friend which recipe she
used for her brownies because it was
really good I hope pry
answers oh no what am I going to do
should I just use the old recipe what
recipe is it I mean I could use preppy
kitchen's recipe they pretty good yeah
I'll just do that but like she was
swearing by this recipe she was like
it's so good why didn't you note it down
I thought I did but I might have just
closed that tab it's not on notion or
something no it's not on my notion I
know I put everything on notion but not
[Music]
this I found the recipe so we need that
chocolate we got the butter we've got
eggs cocoa powder I have we just need
that chocolate and that's it we how how
many eggs four medium eggs we need more
eggs we need more
eggs thank
yous
HS thank you yeah there you go I'm
trying H weather like this exist yeah y
just came from China why did you say it
like that I from China well you did this
a couple of days ago and he visited his
grandparents we need to start cooking
ASAP because kitchen is going to become
too busy nearer to dinner time and
there's not enough space in the kitchen
for everyone to cook at the same time
things already too late but really yeah
it doesn't sound
[Music]
promising
you
[Music]
start okay okay I'll start so I brought
a bunch of Stu food or sorry I got why
do you want to do this people are coming
so just show it to me show me the gifts
please grass jelly milk pow I got
Taiwanese on strawberry ones and Taro
flavor Peach flavor hulong
milty this is original flavor mil thank
you Taro it's called Yen
Yen look how big this is as big as my
head as big as your head actually which
is like even bigger half of these stuff
are milk te related that's all I got I
know you love it you're milk tea
Enthusiast you know what this will save
me so much money because now I can make
it my own that's it pretty much so what
ises that that's uh not for camera why
this like this is special thank you I'll
open that
[Music]
later we're on our way to to no student
accommodation to study together you can
get there it's
ROP sorry I forgot about it take this
one
off it's so
rainy it's a little bit wet are you
actually going to work girl of we're
actually going to work you have work to
do yeah I got some Stu you're not
working with us I
know I could I don't think I up to you
if I finish dinner you're still here
I'll come down how long are you going
when I work finishes I guess okay
fine yes oh yeah there's a desk bigger
over there well the desk over there is
bigger the couches here are more
comfortable which one do you prefer cuz
I all this like a dining table do you
think it's bigger is it plugs your plugs
important plugs okay let's
move so you're oh I think they're coming
back I thought they left I don't want to
still there study
space nice we can
move oh my God
sorry I love studying in my room wrapped
in my blanket but being too comfortable
can lead to progress ination and I've
been feeling that so I'm here to do
practice questions on Psychiatry but
I've been delaying this for so long and
it was raining today and I was like I
want to get out of my room but to break
the cycle I've decided to invite my
friends to join me and change my work
environment and I won't leave here until
I get my work
done have enough space Oh yes thank
you this is the grass jelly Yen brought
from China
this is just
honey can I eat this now yes you can eat
it you don't have to ask me I don't know
you want to get
[Music]
this thanks we can watch
anything was 11 years ago wow to
cold why do you chew like a
squel why do you SL at like an an
[Music]
so I don't have any more honey left just
spit in it no fine don't you said I'm
okay okay it's fine just pour me
some thanks all right let's get back to
[Music]
work so I re for you what you do no no
no no no no no I'm going to hit it nice
do you know how to play with um yes yeah
I do okay
play okay you already don't know how to
play no I know it so basically you just
start with no I mean this that's what I
meant do you think I wouldn't know that
come on go on you're distracting me
don't talk to me
[Music]
please yeah that's what I thought
okay yeah wow that was so good I'm so
proud of
you do have to play it now well then
teach
me you you're watching me play though
like you know how to tell you know you
want to se your hand on the table and
then guide it
[Music]
this so now it's your all right film me
cuz this is going to be epic like that
yeah and then you aim for the Red Bull
so that's fine so you didn't hit
anything in so this now my
[Music]
turn okay you can at
this we're done so glad that I finally
finished all of those like questions
it's been long overdue but what have you
been up to yet writing some job
applications and then researching
different companies and stuff nice yeah
cuz Yen finished his master now
congratulations yeah yeah now I got to
find a job so it's like another thing it
never stops it never
[Music]
stops